Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Qu’est-ce que vous voyez ?
Le jour où on a posé cette assiette
devant moi au restaurant,
je me suis immédiatement
vue devant un lac gelé.
Je n’étais plus à Megève,
mais au Canada, devant le lac Abraham.
Transcender un plat en ayant l’idée
de l’appeler « Le lac gelé »,
c’est mon métier.
Je suis designer culinaire.
Si vous ne savez pas ce que c’est,
rassurez-vous, moi non plus.
(Rires)
Enfin, maintenant si.
Mais pendant des années,
expliquer mon métier a été ma hantise.
Tout le monde me demandait si je faisais
les photos pour les livres de recettes,
les dressages pour les grands chefs
ou si je dessinais des casseroles.
Tout le monde me définissait
par tout ce que je ne faisais pas.
Et un jour, j’ai eu l’idée de me présenter
comme designer au service du culinaire.
Et là, les chefs avec qui
je rêvais de travailler
ont compris que je ne toucherais ni
à leurs assiettes, ni à leur créativité.
Moi, mon dada au restaurant,
c’est toutes les petites attentions
pour l’expérience du client côté salle.
Eh oui !
Tout ne se joue pas en cuisine.
Ça vous est peut-être
déjà arrivé en vacances.
En Italie, vous mangez
de délicieuses lasagnes.
Vous rapportez tout ce qu'il faut
pour les refaire à la maison.
Vous redoublez d’efforts, vous suivez la
recette qu’on vous a donnée à la lettre.
Et c’est moins bon que dans vos souvenirs.
Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Ce que je fais n’est pas réservé
à la gastronomie
et peut être utile
à chacun de nous au quotidien.
Comme cette nuance autour de mon métier,
un détail peut tout changer.
Avez-vous déjà remarqué que tout
ce qu’on mange a une forme ?
Un bagel, une baguette de pain,
un carreau de chocolat,
des spaghettis, une part de camembert,
un hamburger avec des frites,
une saucisse, roulée dans une galette.
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire ?
(Applaudissements)
Une des fonctions de la forme,
c'est la séduction.
On a rarement le coup de foudre pour
quelqu’un qu’on trouve moche, non ?
Dans une vitrine, une petite tarte,
pimpante, jaune citron,
va peut-être plus vous taper
dans l’œil qu’un banal éclair,
pâlichon, tout marronnasse.
Mais attention, comme en amour,
l’apparence extérieure ne fait pas tout.
Un dressage aura beau être superbe,
si le goût n’est pas à la hauteur
de la promesse visuelle,
vous serez déçu et vous ne finirez
peut-être même pas votre assiette.
Le beau nous fait venir,
mais c’est le goût qui nous fera revenir.
22 décembre 2021.
Je ne sens plus rien.
J'ai perdu le goût.
Bon, je ne suis peut-être pas la seule
à qui c’est arrivé ces derniers mois.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais moi,
plutôt que de n’avoir le goût de rien,
je décide de vivre ça
comme une expérience.
Cette année, pour Noël,
ce sera choucroute.
(Rires)
Alors niveau visuel,
ce n’est pas très sexy,
mais c’est le seul plat dont j’ai envie
car j’ai des référentiels en mémoire.
Je me concentre sur mes
sensations en bouche.
L’acidité du chou fermenté
contracte mes maxillaires,
le salé de la charcuterie me fait saliver.
Je peux comparer l’humidité des filaments,
le moelleux du gras du lard
et le duveteux de la pomme de terre,
légèrement sucrée,
me fait l’effet d’un gros câlin.
J’entends bien la saucisse
qui knacke sous mes dents.
Même privée de goût,
tout un tas d’autres récepteurs
ont joué leur rôle.
Manger est l’un des seuls
moments de votre vie
où vous êtes en connexion
quasi simultanée avec vos cinq sens.
La vue, l'odorat, le toucher,
l'ouïe et le goût.
Le goût arrive en dernier
dans les interactions avec votre corps.
Et si on pense à lui en premier, c'est
évidemment parce qu'il a un rôle majeur.
C’est lui qui envoie à notre cerveau
le signal que c’est bon
et de reprendre une autre bouchée.
La gourmandise, c’est lui.
Si le beau nous fait venir
et le bon revenir,
qu’est-ce qui nous fera nous
souvenir de ce qu’on a mangé ?
Replongez dans un de vos plats
ancrés dans votre mémoire.
Est-ce que vous pouvez me décrire
très précisément son goût ?
Me donner la liste de ses ingrédients ?
Ou me raconter à quoi il ressemblait ?
Ou est-ce plus facile pour vous
de vous souvenir qui avait cuisiné ?
Votre grand-mère, votre cher et tendre,
un chef inconnu ou étoilé ?
Étiez-vous un peu stressé
pour un déjeuner d’affaire
ou sur votre 31 pour fêter quelque chose ?
Et les couverts,
étaient-ils en argent ou en plastique ?
Ces dernières questions
peuvent sembler accessoires.
Pourtant, chaque détail compte
autour de ce que vous mangez.
C’est ce que j’appelle le sixième sens,
le sens de l’histoire
qui se joue autour de votre assiette.
Repensez à vos lasagnes en Italie.
Le farniente, la chaleur du soleil
qui vous caresse la peau,
le serveur, charmant,
qui vous raconte
en vous parlant avec les mains
que c’est la mama qui les a
cuisinés avec amore ce matin
dans un italien qui chante.
Vous savourez autant la perspective
sur la piazza Navona que votre plat.
Tout ce contexte,
c’est la caisse de résonance qui décuple
vos émotions autour de ce que vous mangez.
C'est souvent ce qui manque à la maison.
Ce qui ne remet pas du tout en question
vos talents de cuisinier.
Et pour ceux qui n’aiment pas cuisiner,
rassurez-vous,
le secret de vos souvenirs culinaires
est une équation.
C'est la combinaison de ce que votre corps
ressent au contact de vos cinq sens
et tout ce que votre cerveau perçoit.
Tous ces petits détails qui,
s’ils sont sincères et cohérents,
vous touchent en plein cœur.
Quand tout ça est en harmonie,
l'expérience devient mémorable.
Cette équation, c'est la recette de ce
qu'on appelle une madeleine de Proust.
Dans son récit, Marcel Proust ne décrit
pas seulement l’odeur, la texture,
et le goût unique de sa première
bouchée de Madeleine.
Il détaille aussi
tout le contexte affectif
qui a rendu cet instant unique et magique,
et même extrêmement difficile
à retrouver ensuite.
Une madeleine de Proust est
aussi ces bribes de sensations
que l’on revit parfois et qui,
en une fraction de seconde,
nous transportent dans le temps
ou dans l’espace,
vers la joie des crêpes,
des goûters chez mamie,
vers le frisson d’un caramel au beurre
salé chapardé dans la boîte à bonbons.
Ou devant l’image d’un lac gelé.
Pour capter ces moments d’exception,
il faut être attentif
car tout ça est très furtif.
Tout à l’heure que vous ayez repensé
au poulet rôti du dimanche de votre mère,
à un morceau de Saint-nectaire
goûté à la volée sur un marché
ou à un grand plat dans un restaurant
pour un anniversaire,
au moment où vos papilles s’affolaient
avec ce souvenir culinaire,
vous n’étiez probablement pas
en train de regarder un écran
en avalant machinalement en même temps.
Vous étiez là.
Ici.
Maintenant.
Nous les Français, au cours de notre vie,
nous passons près de 100 000 fois à table,
soit presque quinze années à manger.
Vous vous rendez compte ? Quinze ans !
Ça veut surtout dire qu’il nous reste
encore plein d’occasions
de croiser nos futures
madeleines de Proust,
sans rester dans la nostalgie du passé.
Et ça peut être très simple.
Mexique, 2016.
De passage à Playa del Carmen,
mon copain a repéré un restaurant
de tacos cinq étoiles sur Google Maps.
On cherche.
On quadrille toutes les rues
autour de ce supermarché.
C'est désert, on en a plein les pattes.
Et à 14h30, on comprend
que ce n’est pas un restaurant,
mais une camionnette garée là,
sur un coin du parking.
Il fait plus de 40 degrés à l’ombre
et il n’y a même pas un parasol.
À la carte : tacos à la moule,
tacos aux crevettes,
tacos au calamar.
Que des fruits de mer.
Auriez-vous osé commander
quoi que ce soit par cette chaleur ?
Eh bien, c’est ici que j’ai mangé
les meilleurs tacos de ma vie.
Au-delà de leur goût,
ils sont restés gravé dans ma mémoire
grâce à leur histoire,
l’aventure pour les trouver.
Complètement affamés, on était
reconnectés à un plaisir presque primaire.
Et en voyage, encore une fois,
loin de nos habitudes,
on est bien plus sensible
à tout ce qu’on ressent.
Le plaisir que l’on peut avoir
en mangeant n’est pas un luxe.
Parfois, il n’y a même pas une table.
C’est accessible à tous
si on reste en contact avec nos sens
et tout ce qui nous entoure.
Je vous souhaite de ne plus jamais
engloutir une assiette de la même façon.
Le beau vous fait venir,
le bon vous fait revenir.
Mais qu’est-ce qui vous
fera vous souvenir ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)